financé par la région et l'agglomération
l'électro composteur de villepreux est
une solution complète de traitement de
gestion des biodéchets
écologique et économique ce composteur
de taille intermédiaire peut contenir
jusqu'à 160 kg de déchets par jour le
composteur électronique à l'icl c'est le
moyen de composter localement les
déchets sans nuisance est au plus près
des sites émetteurs donc les écoles les
habitants ne peut pas sur des quantités
de bio déchets fermentescibles comme ça
restait sur le compostage classique
manuel on a besoin d'avoir une
manipulation importante donc qui ne peut
être que mécanique on a besoin de remuer
régulièrement pour que ça fonctionne en
quinze jours on a besoin de monter en
température on a besoin de monter à 60
70 degrés donc effectivement la solution
et électromécaniques et la sole qui
correspondent à l'enjeu communal qu'on
s'est dit les circuits courts aussi sur
la thématique de la gestion des déchets
c'est à dire des déchets qui vont
directement de l'assiette au traitement
sans passer par un autre site on est
quelque chose de totalement vertueux
écologiquement parlant des déchets qui
seront récoltés depuis les points
d'apport volontaire à l'aide d'un vélo
électrique avec remorque le compost
obtenu à la fin sera redistribué dans
les espaces verts de la ville et les
jardins partagés par des enjeux de ce
système ces deux d'éviter encore de le
diminuer les nuisances donc on va
remplacer le camion poubelle par un vélo
cargo électrique donc les opérateurs de
la cantine de la cuisine centrale vont
venir collecter les différentes écoles
mais aussi les points d'apport
volontaire en vélo et on va voir du
compost qui va être redistribué à donner
à des associations locales notamment
pour les jardins partagés pour les
jardins solidaires on a aussi nos
services techniques qui vont pouvoir
utiliser ce compost pour leur travail du
quotidien pour des plantations une
action qui a comme objectif à terme de
se développer dans d'autres
collectivités trappe devrait poursuivre
l'expérimentation dans quelques mois
suivi de près par voisins le bretonneux